c'est la visite d'exploitation si bien
mon grand-père était fermier mon père a
été terminé en 6e tellier je suis
agriculteur à saint pryvé dans l'yonne
sur une exploitation de 160 hectares
avec des productions de céréales et
vaches à lait mon père était sur cette
ferme nous on a repris y est il y aura
un fils le fils de mon frère qui il
souhaite évidemment s'installer de
nouveau et ouais elle traite robotisée
est beaucoup plus calme aucune prête
l'entrevue qu'on a on vient de réaliser
qu'il colle à sarkozy nous on la
considère satisfaisante je pense que le
message a été bien reçu
j'ai ressenti beaucoup d'angoissé
beaucoup d'inquiétude l'angoissé celles
ci pourront continuer à faire leur
métier demain on a besoin de
perspectives à long terme
ce n'est pas une crise conjoncturelle
c'est une crise structurelle il faut
sauver l'agriculture française
pour ça il va falloir réinventer un
modèle vous baisser massivement les
charges qui pèsent sur les agriculteurs
et qui les empêchent de vendre leurs
produits
il faut remettre en cause grand nombre
de normes européennes des français ce
qui empêche nos producteurs de prendre
des initiatives
si les agriculteurs ne peuvent pas vivre
et prix des produits qu'ils produisent
c'est tous nos territoires qui seront
désertés qui sont abandonnés c'est un
problème pour l'identité même de notre
je pense qu'il prendra les et les
quelques éléments qu'on lui a données
avec d'autres avec d'autres collègues
dans d'autres régions de france pour
bâtir un projet agricole digne de ce nom
qui donne des perspectives à 20 ans
d'une agriculture française qui en a
bien besoin
je voudrais qu'on tiendra pour dix y est
rond c'est les problèmes qui sont niveau
des consoles plus essayer de construire
les solutions